how does a writer know if prose is
better for them creatively or the
screenwriting format
um I think it's I think they it's just
trial and error
uh I I wrote a screenplay in 2019 right
before covid and um I was jazzed about
it and I'm like let's go let's go and I
wasn't ready to show it yet but I knew
that I had because I knew I had rewrites
to do and then now I'm writing the novel
so I read the characters are intriguing
me so much I'm like I really need to get
in their heads and I real and and when I
write I hand write I I'm not a typer so
I have to handwrite everything and
that's um and that's giving me so much
joy right now because that's just like
I'm finding out things about the theme
and what I thought I was presenting and
I was just like oh no that's not the
theme at all so it's uh
yeah it uh if something's a screenplay
or a book it could be both it's
um
and it could be just a novel and some
novels would be you know really hard to
adapt I I but I I think I would like to
think in myself if anyone asked me to
adapt a novel that was unadaptable I
feel like I could find the thread to do
it
um but that's probably because I get a
little delusional and I want to problem
solved so so you love these characters
so much that you realized that 110 page
whatever screenplay wasn't wasn't enough
for you creatively
yeah um I think yeah I don't know if it
wasn't enough I think there's I don't
think the screenplay is there yet so
that's part of it and I think there's a
lot more to explore and for me the way
to explore it is through pros and
I'm just doing it that way and in the
end I mean it might be a graphic novel
who knows uh I it's almost like you
don't want to you don't want to put it
in a ball too quick let's just let the
story go let's let's see where this
story goes and who you know who knows it
maybe it is just a book maybe maybe it
never was meant to be on the screen at
all or maybe the book gets tossed away
and I learn a couple things and go back
in the rewrite
um I don't think we should I don't think
we should hold on to the the medium so
much that um
you know work through it and try to
complete things but we shouldn't we I
don't think we need to
give the medium so much power let's give
the story The Power
was there a defining book of your
teenage years
so I really couldn't read books in my
teenage years because I grew up the
Jehovah's Witness and I was reading more
bible stuff uh and the and only slid by
in the books that were uh
that were assigned to us in school so
and you know they essentially were like
just try to read enough so you can get
by and get a decent grade and get out it
was it was very discouraged to read
anything that wasn't published by the
Jehovah's Witnesses
um
when
uh so when so what happened was a friend
of mine a friend of mine in the
Jehovah's Witnesses was disfellowshipped
so he was shunned and then he killed
himself and so I went to the elders and
I was looking for help and because I was
because I'm like wait Gibby killed
himself and how can I not kill myself uh
because you know I do have suicide in my
family that's not related to the
Jehovah's Witnesses so
they were completely unhelpful they
didn't want me to grieve his suicide
um they just said make sure you keep
going and preaching and stay and that
was not the answer for me so what I did
and this is I think I was 22 or 23.
so so I went to the library instead and
I went to the psychology section and I'm
like where do I get help so I found Tony
Robbins and I found a Wayne Dyer oh yeah
and I'm like and I and I was like oh and
I would just sit there in the stacks and
read these
and it kind of gave me a little bit of
perspective and then it was next to
poetry and I started and I just started
opening poetry books and I was and I was
just and they were speaking to me
and then somehow the first novel I read
was um Giovanni's room James Baldwin
so I read that book kind of didn't get
it because it's a homosexual love affair
if I remember right I haven't read it
since then
but I got the I got the heart of it
it meant something to me and I was like
who do I read next so James Baldwin was
my number one and then I read Henry
Miller and then I found out that there
was this guy Jack Kerouac who was
who wrote on the road and it was it was
the Beat Generation I'm like what's a
beat and I remember skateboarding to the
library before it closed because I had
to get a copy of on the road that
weekend and read it and I read that and
I went and and these were touching me on
emotional levels it was I was having a
conversation with authors that had died
but they were but they were I was having
a conversation that I never got to have
in my life
and that that's what changed everything
and then I read a book called hunger by
Newt ham soon this Norwegian author and
that's when I went I'm a writer that was
the book where I just went that's it I'm
a writer uh and I'm going full in and
even if I can't eat and I have to die
I'm writing till the end
so
and when did you tell family people in
the church that you were a writer
well I was still married and I was
married so I ended up getting married to
a Jehovah's Witness and I was still
married I told her that um
out and she begged me not to tell anyone
and I didn't and that was very
codependent of me but I was also you
know I was also unhealthy at the time as
well but I was writing at the time and I
was and I started a thing called film
junkie and um and I would go to film
festivals I knew all of a sudden I was a
journalist in 1999 I was like this is
all you got to do so I was going to
these see all these movies before they
were raided because you can't watch
rated R movies in the Jehovah's
Witnesses and then I was writing about
all these movies and then but then they
would come out and be rated R and they'd
be like how did Tony see that and
they're like well it wasn't rated yet
and they'd be like oh okay
um when I was kind of out of the um
out of it so I was actively like writing
and working on my own stuff and it was
starting to get seen around and people
would get in touch uh with my wife at
the time and be like Tony's kind of you
wrote something that didn't seem a
little too Christian you know maybe you
should talk to him about it and then I
would lean in harder and write a you
know sex scene so because I was being
very contrarian at the time and I think
I needed essentially I was getting my
teenage angst out when I was 27 which is
just totally embarrassing you need to
get it out in your teen years but it was
a little later for me
so then you moved to LA and you felt
like that you could be your own person
and and that you didn't feel shame about
writing anything oh I feel shame about
writing everything uh no I did the LA
move didn't happen for a long time I
stayed in San Francisco I was writing
for the San Francisco Chronicle so I was
covering uh books and um music for the
chronicle and I wasn't planning on
moving to Los Angeles
um and then I finished
um Jesus jerk and then I was shopping it
around I got an agent and then I got a
publisher and then so that the book came
out and then the option thing started
happening
where things go to die
so so but it but it was beautiful I got
to work with uh producer
um who runs hunting Lane films Jamie
patrickoff and we worked on
the pitch for the TV series and and I
learned so much
um about like writing pitches taking
notes and he was very gracious with me
and uh you know and then it was just
like that kind of just fizzled out there
you know there's like meh no screw it
and I don't think it was him I think it
was the people that he had interested uh
and then um
and then the book got to Eric Stoltz and
then that's when
he uh he said hey let's
um first off I found out Eric Stoltz was
reading my book and I was just like well
I could just die now we're done you know
and then um yeah and then
then he said uh we need Tony to write
the screenplay so we don't lose the
voice
and I went and I went challenge taken
um so I uh yeah I worked on that uh
really hard and hours and hours on end
um
and so I wasn't oh so I wasn't in La yet
I was I was in San Francisco and he was
he's in New York so we were doing a lot
of back and forth that way and then as
it went in it got delayed and then
shooting was supposed to start another
time it got delayed but I knew I had to
be in La for it
um and so I just got down to La when it
was in pre-production and I sublet my
apartment in San Francisco and I just
would sublet around La
while I was in pre-production and then
uh and some months later we were on set
and on location
so that's how I came to La I was already
very far out of the Jehovah's Witnesses
I was already divorced I was I had
already created a writing life in San
Francisco
and I was I knew it was time to leave
San Francisco but I was kind of thinking
New York because
I was writing for Publications and
going on that angle but
um the nudge to La
brought me here which was it turned out
to be the right choice and uh yeah